the sheriff is about to take on crypto's
wild west
[Music]
imagine being able to print dollars on
u.s soil and doing so without being
regulated
stablecoins are part of the backbone of
the cryptocurrency universe
together accounting for 120 billion
dollars they're used as a place to park
your money with bitcoin ether and other
cryptos are volatile some investors use
them as saving accounts or for posting
margin for trading digital assets
what they all have in common is that
they try to hold an unchanging value in
reference to some other real world
currency like the dollar or euro
and until now there's been very little
oversight the biggest
tether said until 2019 that for every
one of its units outstanding it held a
dollar in reserve
then in february of that year it said it
may also be backed by cash equivalents
and other assets
that makes it like a money market fund
except that it doesn't have to publish
which assets it owns as regulated funds
do the problem is that this can create a
feedback loop into the real economy
if there's a run on tether it may have
to sell its money market instruments
which may create a liquidity crunch in
other debt assets
and that could create a systemic risk
for financial markets
this is why the u.s securities and
exchange commission is paying attention
chair gary gensler has taken a hard line
on cryptocurrencies in general
he's part of the president's working
group along with jerome powell and janet
yellen but new york attorney general
leticia james has gone further
in february she required tether to end
all trading activity with new yorkers
tethers claims that its virtual currency
was fully backed by u.s dollars at all
times was a lie she said
so right now the sheriffs are looking
for a fight and the wild west is about
to be tamed
i'm eddie van der waalt this is
decrypted for more content like this
follow us on your favorite platforms
you